so minecraft has a new update that's
really making me want to play again plus
we're going to talk about the gta
trilogy's new patch and more
after months of waiting part two of
minecraft's caves and cliffs update has
been released bringing with it taller
mountains deeper caves and new biomes
the game's lowest depth is now negative
64. and the deep slate layer found below
y0 is where stone blocks turn into deep
slate blocks and if you're more
interested in height well the new height
limit is why
255 instead of 140 and there are five
new sub biomes for the layers of each
mountain there is mountain meadow
mountain grove snowy slopes lofty peaks
and snow-capped peaks unfortunately
features like the deep dark biome in the
warden that were set to arrive alongside
caves and cliffs have been delayed and
will now arrive in 2022
with minecraft's the wild update
and sticking with updates a big new
patch for gta the trilogy the definitive
edition is out now and it includes more
than 100 fixes for the game's various
issues that have soured the experience
for some this update arrives not long
after rockstar apologized for the
problems with gta 3 vice city and san
andreas acknowledging that the games did
not release in a state that lived up to
the developers own expectations and what
fans wanted to see
the november 30th patch includes general
stability improvements across all three
games and fixes a long list of bugs the
patch also adds a new feature in the
form of a cinematic camera which can be
now toggled off and on for the complete
patch notes head on over to gamespot.com
but the update news doesn't stop there
in response to the negative feedback 343
industries has announced further steps
to help improve the xp and progression
systems in halo infinite's multiplayer
beta community manager john yountovic
ran through the changes on twitter
saying players can expect increased xp
payouts for the first six matches each
day here's the rundown the first match
is worth 300 xp the second and third 200
xp each fourth fifth and sixth 100 xp
each and then your seventh match and up
are worth 50 xp yunzovic went on to say
that 343 understands that players want
to see even more substantial changes to
xp but it might not happen soon
and now for some call of duty news
because warzone is headed to the pacific
on december 8th with vanguard's first
season and activision has dropped a new
trailer to showcase some points of
interest for the new map themed as a
travel ad the trailer shows several
close-ups of caldera locations that
players will be able to visit including
beautiful waterfalls caves farmland and
the map's volcano additionally
activision listed off 15 main points of
interest the map reveal also confirms
that warzone pacific will take players
back to 1944 to fit the time period with
the vanguard integration everyone who
owns vanguard will get a 24 hour head
start to play warzone's new map while
everyone else can start playing on
december 9th and for those who don't own
vanguard warzone's smaller rebirth
island map will still be available to
play even once verdansk disappears
okay so as someone who hasn't played
minecraft in
five years um what should i know uh what
should i be doing first
uh
any tips any tips hit me down below in
the comment section because i'm about to
go on the game pass and hit that
download button right now
and i might be a little lost
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]